[MUSIC]
In our last episode, we discussed
the psychology of grit and how leaders and
enterprises can be built
to withstand crisis.
So we thought it was the perfect
time to revisit an interview
from one of our very first episodes.
In this masterclass,
we'll hear from Stanford Graduate School
of Business Professor Baba Shiv,
whose research focuses on
the neuroscience of decision making and
the practice of innovation,
from Silicon Valley to emerging markets.
>> One thing you gotta recognize
is that at the end of the day,
most human decisions and most human
behaviors are grounded in emotion.
It is not the rational brain.
>> In his experience surveying
hundreds of CEOs over the years,
Professor Shiv has seen companies
deal with all sorts of crises.
Some have flourished,
but some have folded.
In this deep dive, we'll discuss
what distinguishes the survivors,
the mental and physical ways that leaders
can prepare to innovate during crises.
And some distinct advantages shared by
entrepreneurs in emerging markets when
a crisis hits.
[MUSIC]
I'm Darius Teter, and this is
a masterclass by Grit & Growth with
Stanford Graduate School of Business,
the show where Africa and
South Asia's intrepid entrepreneurs
share their trials and triumphs.
[MUSIC]
Much of Professor Shiv's work
is focused on the difference
between what he calls the type one and
type two mindsets.
I'll let him explain.
>> If you have read Daniel Kahneman's book
Thinking, Fast and Slow, it's exactly what
he says, that most of our decisions
are made by fast thinking systems,
what I call emotional systems,
not by slow thinking deliberative systems.
We're going to understand how
does the emotional brain work.
The way the emotional brain is geared to
behave at any given point in time will
depend upon the mindset that prevails or
the mental state that prevails
at that point in time.
Is it a type one mindset or
is it a type two mindset?
So these are terms that
are borrowed from statistics.
In statistics, we have the notion of
the type one error, the type two error.
What is the type one error in statistics?
The fear of making a mistake,
it's a fear of failure.
The type two mindset, on the other hand,
is not a fear of failure,
it's a fear of missing
out on opportunities.
At the end of the day,
it's really not a fear, it is a desire for
new opportunities.
And it comes out that the brain has
two distinct neural circuitries,
one devoted to the risk
averse type one mindset,
another devoted to the risk
tolerant type two mindset.
And the most critical thing about the way
the emotional brain is geared to behave at
any given point in time is that if
the brain is still in a state of stress,
in other words,
still in a type one mindset.
The brain will be unable to switch to
the risk tolerant type two mindset.
And that's why it's so crucial that
you first get into a state of comfort.
This could be, for individuals, could be
in the form of getting good night's sleep,
fitness also makes a big difference.
Practices like meditation, etc., makes a
big difference because it's going to make
the brain a lot more resilient to stress,
which means that the leader
is not often stressed.
Which means that leader's brain can switch
into the risk tolerant type two mindset.
And there's a lot of
research backing this up,
that something like 90 to 95% of human
decisions and behaviors are shaped
non-consciously by emotional brain
systems, not by rational brain systems.
>> So in Baba Shiv's lexicon, the type
one mindset worries about failure,
while the type two mindset
is open to opportunities.
I wondered how these mindsets
actually affect decision making.
>> At the end of the day, what a rational
brain is good at is simply rationalizing
what the emotional brain
has already decided to do.
Which means if you're stuck in a risk
averse mindset, the rational brain will
come in and say, these are the reasons
why you have to be risk averse,
these are the reasons why you
should not innovate, etc.
Whereas if you're in type two mindset,
the rational brain will come in and say,
here are the reasons why you
should take some chances.
And then you can start thinking about
the downstream applications of the simple
principle of the emotional brain
having the type one circuitry and
the type two circuitry.
You'll see some leaders, when the crisis
hits, they will have done all the scenario
planning beforehand,
they might have plan B, plan C, etc.
But that is really very cognitive
in nature, that exercise.
It is when they get into the crisis
when the true leadership capabilities
will begin to emerge.
And you can see that happening among
leaders that when the crisis hits,
they're able to kind of take a step back.
They're able to assess the situation and
then think very creatively about what
can I do to address the challenge.
But even more important,
how can I leverage the opportunities
that this crisis has afforded?
[MUSIC]
>> Of course,
the mind is part of the body, and
our mindset is affected by
our physical condition.
So what can we do to
achieve a type two mindset?
Here's what Baba Shiv recommends.
>> How should a leader go
about managing a crisis?
First and foremost,
the person needs to come down.
First thing I would advise
the leaders to do is get good sleep.
What tends to happen during crises is
that leaders are fighting a lot of fires,
and what they would sacrifice is sleep.
And lack of sleep is a huge detriment.
Because what'll happen is that
if you're not had enough sleep,
what is called restorative sleep, when
all the brain chemicals like serotonin,
dopamine, etc., are coming back to normal.
You're going to naturally, from
a physiological and a brain standpoint,
you're naturally going to wake up being
in a risk averse type one mindset.
That's the last thing that the leader
wants to do in times of crisis.
So get good night's rest.
If you can let your team do that,
do that as well.
Because what is needed out here is not
just the leader, but also the entire team
that is on board to kind of wade through
the crisis, addressing the challenges.
But more importantly,
grabbing the opportunities that
the crisis is going to be afforded.
[MUSIC]
The second thing that I would do is that,
even before any crisis hits,
a leader should get into practices
like meditation, yoga, tai chi, etc.
Now, this might sound like some kind
of yoga master kind of teaching, no.
There's a lot of science behind this
suggesting that if you engage in practices
like tai chi, yoga, meditation,
etc., that slows down your breathing,
your brain is going to become
a lot more resilient to stress.
So when a crisis hits,
get good night's sleep.
And if you're not yet practicing, the
leader is not yet practicing meditation,
tai chi, yoga etc., slowing down their
breath, they should start that practice.
Just to make sure that the brain is
able to go into the innovative or
the type two risk tolerant mindset.
>> There are even ways to physically
measure how prepared your mind is
to deal with stress.
>> So technology is going to definitely
help us going forward, right?
[COUGH] So if you think about how
resilient your brain is to stress is
highly correlated with what is
referred to as heart rate variability.
Heart rate variability essentially taps
into the parasympathetic nervous system.
So we have the sympathetic nervous
system and the parasympathetic.
The sympathetic is
the fight-flight system and
the parasympathetic is the rest-digest
system, calm down, calm down, etc.
If you want to know if your brain
is inherently resilient to stress,
you can easily monitor your
heart rate variability.
There are a lot of ways of doing that,
you can do this with your phone, there
are other ones that are out there, you
can measure your heart rate variability.
And the heart rate variability
essentially is the following.
The heart doesn't beat like a metronome.
We think that it is beating at
regular intervals, it is not.
There's always a fluctuation
between beats, so
it is called beat-to-beat interval.
The beat-to-beat interval will
always have a fluctuation.
The greater the fluctuation,
the greater the variability.
In other words,
greater the heart rate variability,
the more resilient the brain is to stress.
So one of the things that a leader
could do, thanks to technology is to
monitor the heart rate variability
at any given point in time.
Which will tell them, are they in
a position right now to make a decision,
an important decision?
[MUSIC]
>> Many leaders in times of crisis
fall back on tried and true products,
customers and markets.
They go with what they know, or
they take a wait and see approach.
That may seem reasonable, but is it right?
>> So let's think about it,
why is crisis the best time to innovate?
It is Charles Darwin who said that it is
not the strongest of the species that
survives, not even the most intelligence.
The one that is going to survive is
the one that is most adaptable to change.
Which means that yes, you can say,
as a leader, I'll just wait this out, for
six months, fine,
I'm going to emerge from there.
Maybe I'll emerge weaker, but
I'll kind of start from that
point in time and move forward.
But keep in mind,
you're not alone in the market.
There are other players in the market.
And if there's another player in
the market, who, as Darwin said,
is much more adaptable to the change.
They are going to emerge much stronger
than you are going into the future, so
don't assume that your strength
before the crisis is going
to remain the same going forward.
Because there are other players out there
who are probably been doing the right kind
of things in terms of being innovative,
adaptive etc, will go and emerge much,
much stronger.
So the survival of the company
in the long haul, never,
ever comes from sticking
to the status quo.
It always will come from
being adaptable to change,
responding to change that is happening.
And that is where the leader needs
to have an innovation mindset and
the organization as a culture needs
to have an innovation mindset.
What they would do is that, they always
treat the situation as being dynamic.
It is not static.
What it means is that, you have come into
the situation with a lot of assumptions,
preconceived notions, etc.
That's the same thing for leaders as well,
a crisis is a great opportunity for
leaders to come in and
re-assess all the assumptions and
preconceived notions that they have.
Don't try to do what you were doing in the
past because that is not going to help you
address the crisis.
Because you cannot assume that
the world is static anymore.
A crisis is going to be very dynamic.
[MUSIC].
>> Baba Shiv has a simple shorthand for
leaders who bring an innovation
mindset to a crisis.
Innovation equals creativity times
execution and divided by constraints.
And no, that's not a mathematical formula,
but for Baba, it does add up.
>> Generally if I,
if you should ask people of what comes to
mind when the word innovation is uttered.
In general,
people will say innovation is creativity.
Innovation is really not just creativity.
Creativity is an important
component of that,
that requires the innovation mindset,
the type two mindset etc.
But it also requires execution.
You are coming up with certain
hypotheses that need to be tested, and
that requires execution.
The third component here is constraints.
So the way I look at it this, is that
innovation is creativity multiplied
by execution, divided by perceived
constraints or the constraints out there.
The second way to think about
constraints is that, and
I've seen this happening time and
time again.
If I tell you to come up with a solution,
so for example, you're going to Rwanda,
you're looking at a rural home out there,
the integrity of the flooring and
the home is not great.
And if I'm going to tell you, you need
to come up with a solution for this.
Your first thing that you will do is
to say, okay, I'll just make sure,
I'll just find out how much it costs
to put cement and so on and so forth,
not realizing that person will not be able
to spend more than $50 for the floor.
That is a constraint.
So if you bring in constraints very
early on in the design process as you're
figuring out, what is working,
what is not working?
What are the assumptions to be made?
What are the hypotheses etc.
It is always a good idea to
bring in the constraints.
So two things quickly to summarize
about this equation that innovation is
creativity multiplied by execution.
Yes, creativity is important.
Yes, execution is important.
But let's not forget the constraints.
And especially in a crisis situation,
you're bound to face constraints
that are never faced before.
It could be financial constraints.
It could be market constraints.
It could be team constraints.
Maybe a team member has fallen sick,
a critical team member has fallen sick,
those are all constraints.
And innovation comes from being
able to develop your solution and
deliver on your solution
subject to these constraints.
Always a good idea to incorporate
constraints into the design process.
>> Baba Shiv has seen firsthand
that leaders from emerging markets
are particularly resourceful.
Not in spite of their situations,
but because of them.
What I noticed about entrepreneurs
who come out from India, Africa,
be it East Africa,
West Africa, Southern Africa.
One thing I noticed is that
they are extremely innovative,
extremely innovative because they
are facing constraints all the time.
That could be credit constraints,
interest rates are very high.
There is a lack of trust
between the supplier and
they're dealing with all the time.
And I feel that rather than saying
that that is a disadvantage of
being an entrepreneur down the economy,
I would argue it is actually an advantage.
Because inherently you're a lot more
innovative in terms of the creativity,
in terms of execution and going with
the constraints that are out there.
You're far better equipped to handle
crisis than someone who is probably in
the more Western,
more developed kind of economies.
And also one of the things that they
quickly realize in these developing
economies is that,
because of all the constraints,
because of all the struggles
they have to go through.
When given an opportunity to collaborate
with other business leaders,
they jump onto that opportunity
much sooner than people in more
developed economies will do.
Because in developed
economies you can say, yeah,
I'm going to raise more money and
I can solve the problem.
Yeah, I can hire more people,
Yeah, I can pay more or pay less and
give a discount I can solve the problem.
The business leaders in many of
the developing economies that I have
encountered out there,
don't go with that kind of assumption.
The first thing is not
going to raise more money,
is it who can I reach out to in my
network so that I can get some help?
And that, it's a very natural process that
they go through which is why you're seeing
now, we are seeing this right in
front of our eyes as we speak.
All the collaboration that is happening
among the business leaders who have
attended the C program.
[MUSIC]
>> Part of what makes a crisis
such a fertile time for
innovation is that it turns
the world on its head.
>> If you go with that assumption
that the world is dynamic,
what that allows you to do is first
get rid of preconceived notions.
And start looking at what new assumptions
I have to make going forward, and
how do I go about testing
those assumptions?
It's one thing to simply go about coming
up with new assumptions out there.
The other thing is to
actually execute on that,
which means you need to
test these things out.
So I would always advocate a leader
during a crisis to consider the situation
to be dynamic, even more so
when we are not in a crisis situation.
Go back to the drawing board and
ask the fundamental questions,
is that what assumptions have I
come into the situation with.
That is all assumptions that are come from
the past, what assumptions need to be
relaxed, what new assumptions or
hypothesis need to be formed.
Ask yourself what is
the business that you're in.
And very often I see entrepreneurs
making the mistake they say that,
I'm in the business of
selling pineapple juice.
No, you're not in the business
of selling pineapple juice,
you're in the business of quenching thirst
with a beverage that tastes good, and
is also healthy, and is also nutritious.
Okay, so if that is how you define
your business, why rely on pineapple,
I might find a local fruit in the country
where I can utilize my same production
facility, to create a beverage that is
no longer dependent upon pineapple.
If it works, then how do you replicate
that, if it doesn't work that's fine.
You at least learned, you'll fail fast,
you'll fail cheap, and
you'll fail forward, in the sense that
you'll learn something from the situation
that you can now apply to
the crisis situation going forward.
[MUSIC]
It is in terms of crisis that
the true mettle of a leader,
is going to be determined.
And which is why, if you go to a VC and
you are a startup, you've started failed,
you go to for the next venture,
you go and knock on the door of a VC, and
say I want to raise money.
The VC is not going to say the last
business you started and you failed.
What they're going to say is that, you
will learn a lot from the failure that you
went through, which means you're
going to be a lot more mature.
Which means you're not going to repeat
the same mistakes that you committed in
the previous startup.
>> Part of innovation is messing up.
But in many cultures, the fear of
failure can stifle experimentation.
>> We 2007/2008 time period,
the Department of Science and
Technology in India had asked
me to come down and do some,
work with them about how do we
foster entrepreneurship in India.
I started talking to some of the best
students from the best universities,
most of them engineering schools in India.
And I was shocked to learn that the top
10% of the class, irrespective of
the university I went to and
asked the students, you want to innovate,
you want to become an entrepreneur,
but let me ask you a question?
You can either be an innovator or
you can be an entrepreneur, and
that's a big difference out there.
You can innovate stuff and
then sell off the IP to someone else.
Entrepreneur requires you
actually have to run a company.
And I asked every one of these
students that have met up,
would you like to be an entrepreneur?
And invariably,
this is 2007 time period, they said no.
And I asked, why?
And that's how you got to understand
the culture of the place.
Imagine that a young kid
in an engineering school,
okay, 20, 22 years old,
has a job offer from the Tatas.
The person cannot make career decisions on
their own, that's the culture of India,
and many of the Asian countries, and
also countries in Africa by the way.
Where, if I have to make these career
decisions I have to consult my parents.
I have to consult my uncle,
my aunt ,and so on and so forth,
there are multiple people out there.
If I'm this young person going
to my parents and saying,
I have a job offer from the Tatas, but
I want to go into entrepreneurship,
what do you think the parents
are going to say?
[LAUGH] They're going to say, [LAUGH]
you are stupid, is how I brought you up?
And therefore, when you're designing the
solutions you gotta be acutely aware of
the cultural context
that we're operating in.
And it's absolutely right that
in most cultures out there,
failure is not tolerated, failure is
ridiculed, sometimes even punished, right?
That's kind of state out there.
Hopefully what the Graduate School
of Business is doing,
because that is the mission of
the Graduate School of Business,
is to change lives,
change organizations, change the world.
Is for us to create this ecosystems,
where failure is no longer
going to be seen as double.
Yes it is going to take time, but the hope
is that within one generation 20 years
that we think about, these delicate
economies where this culture of failure or
against failure is so deeply embedded,
we're looking to change.
And we're beginning to see the change,
I mean from 2007 to 2017,
there was a massive change in what I
was observing on the ground in India.
Where now young kids in the top 10% of
their class, they don't want to go and
work for a large corporation, which is
no different than the Stanford GSB.
They want to work in a startup, either an
early state or growth state startup, why?
Because that taboo has disappeared.
And why does that happen?
That's because now there are role models.
There are people who started
companies like Flipkart in India,
etc, who become very successful.
Now the parents are saying, yeah you have
an offer from the Tatas but I don't want
you to go and work in the Tatas out there,
that is a previous generation.
I would rather you go and
start a company and
make it into the next
Flipkart of the world.
[MUSIC]
>> Baba has outlined a series of steps for
a leader to get in the right
mindset to tackle crises.
From challenging assumptions while
recognizing constraints, to searching for
opportunities to innovate,
and embracing failure.
But I wondered,
how does a leader bring their team along,
how do they foster a type two
mindset throughout the organization?
>> If everyone is stressed,
generally what tends to happen is
people will go into their own shell.
Because it's a survival mode, I have
to survive first before I start helping
others and
start collaborating with others.
It is the leader's job to kind of say,
let us go through this whole thing.
Forget about whether you win or
lose, ask yourself the question,
are you going to feel proud
with yourself of what you did?
And you going to feel proud,
when you're giving your best.
And that's the leader's job.
The leader's job is to have the internal
team members, get out of the state of
stress, knowing that our survival
is going to come from teamwork.
And the second critical factor
that they have to be looking at,
the leaders have to be doing is, for
the team members to kind of put in place
the culture and the space out there.
So that they can start now reaching out
and collaborating among one another.
And that's a leader's job.
The leader's job is to tell the staff
out there that, it is not about losing,
it's not about winning out there,
but let us feel proud.
And let us be proud in such a way
that when we emerge from the crisis,
we will have emerged much stronger.
Not the company, not the leader, but
all of us collectively have emerged
from it feeling much stronger.
Failures could have happened, that's okay.
[MUSIC]
>> One thing we've learned over the past
18 months, is that big exogenous shocks
like the pandemic are experienced not
just as a crisis for each company,
but as a series of interrelated, and
sometimes reinforcing crises
throughout supply chains in markets.
So focusing all your energy internally,
maybe a missed opportunity.
I asked Baba how leaders can draw
on external resources in crisis.
Do leaders have potential
allies with shared interests?
>> People often talk about competitive
advantage, and don't get me wrong,
that is important, in other words,
how is your value proposition superior
than that of your nearest competitor?
That's a competitive advantage.
But people forget that there is a second
element which is referred to as
collaborative advantage.
Now, collaborative advantage, very often,
is about how do you
manage your dependencies?
So you might have suppliers out there,
you have customers out there,
your have distributors out there,
these are all relationships.
What do we often end up doing in trying
to create a collaborative advantage?
We adopt a transactional approach.
The transaction approach means that
we're going to sign some contracts.
If there's any violation of the contracts,
then we can go to the court of law and
have that adjudicated,
and so on, and so forth.
But guess what?
In a transactional approach,
will give rise to a lot of suspicion.
People are suspecting one another,
they don't divulging
information with one another.
It's an adversarial
kind of a relationship.
The true collaborate advantage comes
when one adopts a relational approach,
not a transactional but
relational approach.
And if you go to many of the Asian
countries, you'll kind of notice that.
Go to Japan, for example, you will never
be able to break into the Japanese market
unless you have created a very strong,
deep relationship with the key partner
that you're looking for in Japan, because
everything is based on relationship.
And at the core of relationship,
the relationship approach of creating
collaborative advantage,
is building trust.
[MUSIC]
It is in times of crisis when everyone
is struggling, it's not just you,
you're not alone in this, there are other
people also who are struggling out there.
How do we go to these important
strategic partners, and suppliers, and
distributors, etc,
not with a transactional approach?
And guess what, when you adopt that kind
of relational approach that your partner
has also been doing,
people will feel grateful for that.
They will always remember you
that in times of difficulty,
when even your partner didn't have
the money to pay salaries, etc.,
that leader was able to do
something to help people out.
And people never forget that,
never, ever forget that.
And you're going to develop
a deep level relationship,
not only amongst your team members.
And your partner is doing the right thing,
they're developing that kind of
camaraderie to monitor the prices.
But even your strategic partners
out there, your suppliers and
distributors, are going to kind
of look at you very differently.
That you're not just here for
a transactional gain,
where it's just an exchange that is
taking place, but you're here for
a collaborative gain that
all of us are going to win.
[MUSIC]
>> I asked Baba Shiv to summarize
some actionable takeaways for
CEOs facing a crisis.
>> So let me give some thoughts here for
any leader who is going through a crisis,
okay.
First one, remember that you are in
a unique position to not only survive,
but emerge from the crisis being stronger.
And you have the capabilities to do that.
And if you don't, you gotta build it.
The second one that I would say is,
always think about not just competitive
advantage, think also about
collaborative advantage.
And think about collaborative advantage
that comes not from just a transactional
approach, comes from
a relational approach.
And what it means, is building meaningful
connections that are grounded in trust.
If you're already in a crisis right now,
hopefully you have prepared for
the crisis.
So keep in mind that the people who
are better prepared are going to be
the winners.
But you can't prepare for
every single crisis.
So preparation is not just
about scenario planning.
Preparation is not just about thinking
about various strategies, and
outcomes, and so on.
Preparation comes from the fact
that do I have the capabilities,
which is the emotional capabilities,
to deal with the crisis, number one.
And number two,
does my team have the capabilities,
the emotional capabilities,
to be innovative at times of crisis.
And the third takeaway is that it
is a leader's job to make sure that
the organization is adaptable to change.
And it's a leader's job to ensure
that that organization emerges from
the crisis a lot stronger than before.
And at the root of that
is an innovation mindset.
[MUSIC]
>> Baba Shiv believes companies that take
these steps are better positioned to win
in the future.
>> If you think about the long
term success of any organization,
in my humble opinion, that is going to
come from times of crisis like this,
and this is universal.
But what these leaders would kind of learn
from this is the importance of maintaining
connections with one another,
meaningful connections with one another.
And creating a collaborative advantage
that is truly grounded in meaningful
connections, truly grounded in trust,
rather than a transaction approach.
So I believe that this
period that we are in,
where the leaders from Africa,
from India, etc., are innovative,
I think it's going pay off
huge in terms of long-term,
because what we're going to observe
from this crisis is success stories.
And these are not
short-term success stories,
these are going to be long
term success stories.
>> I want to thank Professor Shiv for
sharing his insights on how to prepare our
bodies and minds to lead through crisis.
And for encouraging entrepreneurs across
the world to work together in these
difficult times.
[MUSIC]
This has been a masterclass from Grit and
Growth with Stanford Graduate School of
Business, and I'm your host, Darius Teter.
In an upcoming episode, we will hear from
Matt Abrahams, a Stanford lecturer and
the host of the popular podcast,
Think Fast, Talk Smart.
Matt will share invaluable advice for
how to communicate your big idea.
I hope you'll join us.
[MUSIC]
If you want to find out more about
how Stanford Graduate School
of Business is partnering with
entrepreneurs throughout Africa and
South Asia through Stanford Seed,
visit us at seed.stanford.edu/podcast.
If you liked this episode, don't forget
to hit follow and share it with a friend.
Grit & Growth is a podcast
by Stanford Seed.
Laurie Fuller researched and
developed content for
this episode with additional
research by Jeff Pickett.
Kendrick Gladys,
she's our production coordinator.
And our executive producer
is Tiffany Steeves.
With writing and production from
Isabel Polard and Andrew Ganim, and
sound design and mixing by
Alex Bennett and Lower Street Media.
Thanks for joining us.
We'll see you next time.
[MUSIC]